in this capsule we are going
introduce the context of two-game
opponents in artificial intelligence
so our goals in the next
capsule is to arrive at
understand what is the general eighth note
to develop intelligences
artificial games in a context of
two opponents we see the algorithm
mini max as well as its variant plus
effective alfa beta pruning and then
finally we'll see how we comment
can apply these types of algae to
rhythm in there context we are
time constraints then against him that
our algorithms run in real time
let's start with a research reminder
heuristic with for example by stars
so let's imagine we're a game
puzzles have an initial configuration
and the purpose of the game is actually armed
a final configuration that allows us
to solve lines which indicates
we won the game
so to attack the problem like that
we have seen that we must take define
a notion of state that conflict that
finally defines the configuration of the
game that corresponds to a draw in our
search space when searching
with antoine
these are to determine an initial state on
must also define a function of
transition that allows us for each
state of the game to define what are the
successor states to note current rates
which essentially determines
what are the actions that we can
take and where do these lead
actions there to see also
finally a goal function that we
identify a configuration
final of the game so it allows us
to identify that we arrived at a
final which corresponds to win the kind
question
so is it possible
to attack jo where we have two
opponents or more with an algorithm
by stars after all we could
really imagine how we could
set a state for the game so we
think about games at chess games we have
two opponents ben the state would allow
to identify the position of all
pieces on the chessboard function purpose in
this case could simply identify
what are the configurations that are
they do it before these are
they that the player won the game
on the other hand where we will have a problem
if to define our function tradition
actually but if we decide to
move a room that's good
determined we know what will be the
game configuration right after
we will move our piece by cons
do not know the strategy our
adversary and so we do not know which
will be the configuration of the chessboard
after the opponent and play so
next moment we will be able to take
a decision as a player so at
because of his own who directly to
stars in the context of games with
several hours one or more
adversaries and so the assumption that they
violated in this case it's like
conducted in an environment context
multi agents and the opponent player
since it can change the environment
because of that it does not define
perfectly our transition function has
used in our research in the
graph of the game when talking about gambling
with opponents we can have several
behavior makes them opponents
which would correspond to functions of
different transition finally we do not
adversaries who are cooperative
that is to say that they too are trying to
like us to get to the goal then in
what if they reach the goal
corresponds to a victory of everything
all members of the team so all
the players of the game we have contexts where
we have opponents who are
competition so where a player's win
is a loss for others
players a particular case this is it
called sum games
where the heroes are games so it's this
aspect among others during a game
chess or the loss or gain of a
player is completely compensated by a
loss that to the players so we can
imagine a context where we have a tournament
chess where there would be money in
game both players but very much
the money at stake is actually the winner
will win all the money which means
that a player's cash prize is
compensated by a money loss talking
to the players and we finally have
mixed context or made it an opponent
can have an advantage to train
some alliances and so we find ourselves
a little bit between a purely cooperative game
and game that will match will then
really an opponent between the players
so in the next capsule we're going
in fact make the following assumptions to
know that we play only two
opponents that players play one to
the rest of the others each turn
we have a zero sum game that we have a
environment that completely observe
so that means that every player
knows perfectly the configuration of the
of the environment this contrasted with
a game like starcraft or one to the concept
of English fog of war said that a
player does not have any information on
the configuration of the water base
players so here we have this meal in a
context like that we will ask that
the whole environment is observable by
all the players and finally we're going
replay with an environment
deterministic so there will be no
chance or uncertainty about the results
of a player's action on
the environment